Hi, we're back. Um, so yeah, so, uh, I dunno,
dude. Well, you know what?
We should watch that I never watched on this podcast and I don't know how I
never watched on this podcast, uh, is are these things.
And I can't believe we,
I never watch it and I thought it would be a good thing to watch with you. Um,
I can't believe I never watched these, but the, to catch a predators. Oh my God.
These guys, well,
the way they try to lie as the best, I was watching one,
the pizza that guy had a pizza, he brought a pizza, or this is the,
this was the, this one dude. He brought a pizza.
Had Saturday night in the Connecticut. First of all, dude,
how many syllables does the word? It have it's Saturday.
And it IELTS you Saturday night
in the Connecticut suburbs. Autumn is in the air.
I mean the way and this guy pizza. Uh, so,
so far nothing, this guy is bringing pizza to little or lend.
It looks like Robocop is looking at them, look at this text.
But I don't understand that these guys text these things to who they think is a
13 year old, you know, I could be put in jail.
If the police found out we were intimate sin criminal. That is,
that is the worst thing to text someone. Yeah, because that means that, okay.
So, you know, you're no, yeah, you can't what you're doing is really bad. Yeah.
Dude, this guy is essay and secure when he gets caught. Dude. It's unbelievable.
So dude, he is there and she thinks she's 13 years old.
She's laying it on thick and she's laying on thick too. She's like 20 something,
you know? And she's like ma killing it, do an acting. In the meantime,
if I was in this situation, which I'd never be,
I would never be in this situation. I would be like,
she's laying it on too thick. That's a girl who's been to acting class.
She's 22. But this guy is hoping so much that it's for real,
like a perf Bryce.
So nervous. Wow. No expectations whatsoever now.
Oh, look at the guy. He says no, but look, well,
look what she comes out and look when he comes in You're Jeff,
right? Yeah.
Like, like he's the dummy. Yeah.
Hanging out, hanging out with him, with our food.
I want to know who you are.
Flipped right back the way he takes the water. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
So nervous to grab water like that.
What are you doing?
You here tonight. Jeff hanging out with the way he grew up to water. Yeah,
because he has to do something
a little bit more about you first.
You first.
Ah, could I eat? Can I eat first? And then he goes, sure.
He's so relaxed and convinced of his innocence. He eats a slice of.
Pizza. Come in. Who you are is, you know,
relaxing.
He is bumbling so hard with the pizza dude.
It's so weird that this guy chose to eat pizza. And this is the weirdest,
weirdest thing.
Also for any of these to act like they don't know who Chris Hanson is. Yeah.
I don't know. Maybe this was nice. This wasn't a while ago. I don't know.
I don't get it.
Boston man drives two and a half hours to Connecticut to bring pizza to a 13
year old girl that meets Chris Hanson instead said basics direct to the point.
Didn't know there would be other people here. No, man. Well,
what did you expect to happen?
Didn't have any expectations.
Oh, well you, definitely expected to eat some pizza. I'll tell you that much.
Yeah.
So you drove two and a half hours. Sure. It did from Boston. I like it.
We own certain parts of it. You know,
did not a crime against driving two and a half hours is there. Right?
Dude taking the pizza. The cheese is connected from the end to the pizza.
Can't get it off and just relaxes into it and says,
who are you? Is the most balling?
Like I actually think he could maybe get away with it with that.
If he was just that. I mean, he's just like, listen guys,
let's cut to the chase. Who are you? Pizza dude. Well,
he gets caught being a pedophile. I know.
Well what else is he going to do at this point? He's. Yeah.
You have to just eat the at least enjoy the pizza. I guess last meal. Yeah.
Your dad to meet a young girl and you work on, we'll get to that in a minute.
Look at, go ahead and have a bite. Sokol probably should have brought napkins.
A demon dude. Yeah.
Eating pizza gets caught being a pedophile and is like just munching on
pizza like that too. Getting it like a slopped.
Somebody what's wrong. Is that to meet a young girl? He has against the law.
Yeah. Is after this camp, how
did you bring some kind of a contract with you? Some sort of marriage contract.
You had a marriage contract with him that he wanted her to sign. Look,
it looked like a laughing at familiar while you enjoy your pizza, slammed him.
I should come see Saturday. Since your mom isn't home.
It's the best time to do it. I would. But only if you want me to,
I mean, eating the pizza is making me hungry. I can't go to jail.
My life would be ruined. Right.
Right, right. That sounds like me. That sounds like me. Right. Right.
I see you do a great, that can't go to jail. Life will be ruined. Wow.
That was a good one. Got to see if we can get that.
My life would be ruined. Right? It could be like that for 20 years.
Yup. Yup. That's about it. Could we like over 20 years? Yeah. Yeah.
Oh wow. I can see why, you know, a girl would like this guy,
just his confidence.
You say, do you trim your blank? Okay.
Oh yeah. It was okay. It sounds like me too. Yeah. Okay. Okay.
I'm gonna bring that up. Okay, great. You gonna bring that up?
That scroll is 13, right? One chart.
Uh, wow. Wasn't sure. So he says it wasn't you.
How old are you? Might as well just tell me.
Cause I can find doc like that. Who are you? Can you tell me who you are first?
I will tell you that. Cause you know, now you're, you're making me nervous and.
Oh yeah. You're making me want to stop eating my pizza.
Kind of losing my appetite. Honestly. He's pieces of pizza,
eating housing, that pizza two and a half hour drive housing.
That pizza. What? I mean housing? Yeah. housing days.
it's like around,
around like a tree trimmer or like a where they call them free.
What do you call it? Log cutter.
Talking to 13 year old girls like this and I want to,
what am I supposed to make of that?
Sorry for meeting me. No, potentially having.
Oh, okay. So I mean stint, first of all, I don't understand these guys.
When this guy shows up, how do you not believe Matt broke the set?
How do you not leave immediately back?
Just leave when that happens immediately. Ah right.
I'm hungry. Uh, yes. I don't know, dude. I don't. I don't.
Well he's he's so he is so
scared. Well of course he is. Well obviously,
but that's that explains every weird, up stupid thing he's doing.
Like his brain is clearly not working. He knows it's Chris Hanson. Right?
He knows how he is. He knows he's never going to eat a pizza again and his life.
Right.
Where that's all he's going to be eating or that's all he's going to be eating.
And now I can't stop thinking about how my voice is sounding like that.
Or hat's all he's going to be eating from now on,
in jail. You know, she's 13, don't you? I,
I have it right here. What you mentioned with, tell me who are you?
I will get to that. I'll let you know when,
why won't Chris Hansen tell him who he is because he,
he knows once he tells him that, that who he is and who he's with.
I think I was going to leave and he wants to get good television.
So it's just entertainment value. But also Chris Hansen,
didn't he have some come out about him. Now. You didn't know about this.
Did yeah. Chris Hanson, uh,
what would I call it? Uh, what would I type in
bounced? A bunch of checks really? Oh, I thought you meant like, no, no, no.
He did. He had some like some other stuff. Uh, Oh wow.
I looked up one of the investigations and like 26 dudes that they had arrested
26 or something, right?
No, he it up and they went free.
But also I thought he had his own things where he was like trying to
come up front man or something. Not, no, you're not young girls,
but now maybe I just made that up. I probably just made it up.
I don't want to say that this is a story and I will never ever watch this
YouTube video that begins like that.
So nevermind hate when a video says it's a thing. Yeah, dude.
Just introducing it. Yep. Get you out of there. Yeah. Get your view. Count up.
Why are you in the video of Chris Hanson?
It'll be like new MNM song and you'd be like click and be like, what's up,
you know, Eminem came out with a new song and I'm like,
that's up to do that by my buddy, you know, friends now. Right, right, right,
right. Yeah. M and M yeah. Yeah.